um but yeah just having to teach them
how to eat a sushi as well because uh
the the first thing with your mouth the
first thing okay is is this like I
thought it would be obvious right you
have like one piece of sushi a piece of
sushi is like a bite yes and I saw like
a first thing uh some of her family
members did uh was like bite half of it
they're probably just precarious they're
probably just a bit scared of it yeah
they're probably like oh it's a piece of
raw meat uh maybe it's a type of fish
I've never had so let me just take a
test bite I don't want to eat the whole
thing in case it [__] sucks yeah you
know so I got it yeah I mean uh maybe
they have small mouths I don't know no
because it was it was uh it was it was
interesting just to see how the their
approach to like even like the smallest
things
um and just seeing all of the different
types of fish as well because you go to
sushi and they were used they they had
sushi before but it was basically only
tuna and salmon yeah well thank God they
have those yeah yeah salmon is like the
Gateway it's like just should I try the
salmon first this is really different
yeah but if you if you're stuck on the
tuna and salmon you you just might as
well not go into that rather all you
know exactly exactly and then just uh
seeing them have a salmon Row for the
first time and you made them eat salmon
Row the first time yeah I mean I I got I
got the sushi platter oh sorry
I bet they didn't like that
mixed mixed mixed opinions mixed
opinions but it's weird because like you
see salmon row and like some some
westerners are like no fish eggs no but
then you see caviar as like this you
know sought after kind of like very
expensive fish eggs as well and I'm like
is it a mental thing I think I think
it's the size of them and I I don't know
for me the first time I remember it was
how red they were it's kind of weird
like for some reason the because caviar
is black I never thought about it much I
never put much I think it's also because
like seminar is also like slightly yeah
like translucent as well so you can see
the inside like red part too so it
really looks like some frog eggs or you
know like some like some eggs like
actually unusual to have spherical stuff
like that and small think about think
about Western food what is the the
closest comparison to Salmon row that
like we that we often eat like there is
no like we don't have other than regular
eggs yeah yeah right yeah like like my
point is if you if you gave someone
caviar in uh the UK but you spread it on
a piece of toast they'd be like what the
[__] yeah
because they're like this is a like I
don't associate this this shape in this
a quantity is food I know it sounds
weird but I think that's generally
spherical things are the closest thing I
could think of was like Tapioca And that
didn't get like like that's not really
that popular as well though yeah that
didn't get popular until like the past
few years like bubble tea and stuff like
that I do think uh uh when you're being
trying to get people to try new foods
and being open with it yeah I think the
food resemble other foods that they eat
is a lot yeah like the fish right I
think the biggest obstacle is that this
looks like nothing that I eat yeah yeah
right if you gave me a meat substitute
like any kind of wild animal people
don't bat an eye because they're like it
kind of looks like it just looks like a
beef chicken so you're like oh I know
what this is going to taste like then
you try it and you're like oh that's a
bit it's a bit weird it's a bit
different I think I think it's the fact
that it looks different you can clearly
see the texture is different you're kind
of expecting the worst right yeah right
I mean okay I have a confession the
first time I came to Japan I had the
sushi and I think I just wanted to like
it so badly that I pretended I liked it
more than I actually did because I
really wanted to I Really but I I think
at that point I I I've been super
British my entire life and I'd never had
anything even like I'd barely ever eat
like just salmon yeah like raw it was
always grilled yeah or steamed right
like I never had even raw salmon so even
even the raw sound was like a step for
me where I was like oh yeah um and it
wasn't only until after I lived here and
actually forced myself to kind of you
know eat it a little bit every now and
then and then eventually you get like a
weird craving for it and then you start
then you kind of realize oh I think I
like this a lot now yeah
um Sydney often tells me I don't know if
this is true at all but Sydney often
tells me that your taste buds change
every like every few years or something
like that I think so and I don't know if
it's like that exact time but I did
definitely evolved yeah and I'm like my
like I'm like what are your sources
Sydney and she's never given me my time
but like I I can say from personal
experience especially with sushi um I
grew up I grew up thinking Sushi was
like disgusting right like that was you
there was like something about every
time someone was eating sushi something
about the fishy smell of sushi like the
smell the smell of like the soy sauce
specifically because uh you know true
true Sushi soy sauce has like that a
little bit like that fishy kind of like
sea smell yeah you just like fish oil
yeah like I like fish oil and that smell
always put me off and I was I remember
growing up I was like I hate sushi don't
like it it's gonna make me throw up and
then I remember like when I was about 23
or something I remember the exact moment
because I was on a date with Sydney
um and this was like the first few
months that we were dating and she'd
ordered Sushi and I'd never I'd never
even thought Sushi came close to
appetizing in fact it was like sickening
for me she ordered Sushi it was like
basic ass like cheap salmon sushi
somewhere in London not even like
Gourmet Sushi it was just like cheap
salmon sushi and I remember just
yeah it was a Japanese restaurant right
um and I remember the sushi play coming
out and something in my mind just like
clicked and something my mind just went
that don't look so bad actually yeah
that happens a lot I find myself wanting
to try foods that I think I remember I
didn't like yeah again even if I if I
dislike them again but I want to try
yeah yeah yeah absolutely yeah and I
remember I remember I remember telling
Sydney like before before we started
dating I was like yeah I hate sushi you
just like don't if we're gonna go on a
date somewhere go somewhere where I can
order something other than Sushi if
you're gonna order sushi I remember she
ordered that plate I looked at it for a
second and I was like can I have a bite
can I can I try that yeah and she was
like really surprised and I tried it and
my brain was just like oh you like this
now this is this is this is actually
slapping like you need to get more of
this I went from like hating Sushi to
now Sushi is like one of my favorite
Japanese dishes like I Sushi is the one
dish where I have not I have not got
bored of after moving to Japan yeah yeah
for sure I love fish now a lot yeah all
right like even when I go to like
America or the UK If there's a grilled
fish on the menu I'm like dude yes I'll
take that over a steak and another fish
I used to hate mackerel as well [__]
love mackerel Knuckles right but I
remember he had such a strong fishy
taste when I was a kid yeah and my mum
would cook it every now and again I'd be
like okay this is this is the [__] food
day okay thanks man thanks I have to
cook macro okay I don't had it in Japan
I'm like I [__] love my I love
macaron now yeah I when I uh you know
when I was on the chicken and broccoli
Diet I lost a lot of weight yeah because
chicken broccoli was my like that was my
dinner but for lunch a lot of the time I
used to just go to like Aldi and I would
just buy those uh canned mackerel oh
yeah it was like in tomato yeah yeah
because there was like 100 calories and
it's like a ton of protein and I would
just eat canned mackerel like every day
because you could heat it up in a pan as
well yeah it was so good I love mackerel
I've always loved it and sardines too
even though they're a little bony
sardines are okay I like sardines but
man it's like they it's like they've
been designed to spite humans for
farming them because the little
crunchiness and sometimes there's so
many bones yeah yeah yeah for sure yeah
have you ever had your taste buds change
because oh you seem to be someone who
likes everything Joey truly I didn't
used to like concrete and now I'm a big
fan
I just started chewing on my mattress
one day and I was like oh it's actually
kind of good no it's um when I was like
uh up until maybe around like middle
school high school I base I I despite
what you know that scene in old boy
where he eats the octopus yeah I just
hit this vision of Joe watching it being
like [__] I wish that was me
he's the live octopus
Joey's like damn I don't actually like
that yeah wait what live octopus yeah
I've had it before in Japan what yeah
what the [__] yeah if I know I told you
when I went to okayama for a sponsored
video this was [__] like five six
years ago what's wrong with you dog we
went to this restaurant
the guy like he's brought out alive and
they he [__] decapitates and cuts the
legs in like a matter of like 15 20
seconds to the point where yeah the
tentacles are still wriggling around and
they give it to you and they're like eat
it and you have to chew it like a lot
because if you don't chew it enough then
the suction cups can get stuck in your
throat
[Music]
and I ate it I'm like this is the
freshest [__] like octopus Sashimi
I've had in my life probably because it
was a live 20 seconds no life that's the
best spice you know yeah I love it I
love it when I swallow and the life just
drains out of whatever I just ate no but
um like when I was in Middle School High
School like I
basically couldn't eat most vegetables
like legit like growing up the only
vegetables I actually enjoyed eating was
cucumber and lettuce
you mean the closest thing to walk yeah
amazing
any vegetable that had any like
vegetable flavor
basically I really wanted sullivanous
I couldn't eat it like I hated carrots
onions like tomatoes like peppers I
still think carrots are like seitier
vegetables I'm
like the best but you know I can eat
them now before I used to like I
couldn't even eat them I was like I
[__] hate all of these and then just
one day for some reason I was out with
some friends and uh there was like a
small little like salad I think with
like whatever I was eating and it had
like you know like carrots and you know
everything that was you know with
lettuce and cucumber and I was like
that's how we get them boys yeah and
then and then yeah it was kind of the
same thing with you with the sushi I
just looked and I'm like that kind of
looks good
and I don't know why and I and I ate it
and I was like oh I actually kind of
like this now like salad tastes good
vegetables vegetables taste good and now
like yeah I can pretty much eat all
vegetables now yeah and it's so weird
and and I don't remember what happened
or like what conditioned me to like
suddenly be like that but just one day
yeah like it just clicked in my head I'm
like you can eat this now it's like okay
you're free yeah you're free you can eat
this now you have unlocked a new part of
your brain you've ascended a new level
you may now enjoy vegetables you unlock
the skill tree or vegetables you're good
now I've been just here what Sushi they
didn't didn't like what was it yeah yeah
what was like the okay how far did you
go down I I I didn't go that far okay
because I kind of just uh so you didn't
go down like the sperm sack right I
wouldn't do that I saw I saw the shirako
and I I and I was just like they they
are looking at cuttlefish like it's an
alien thing right now so I'm just like
uh which was something
which one's that one what's that
Japanese cuttlefish is like the small
squid looking yeah it's like the white
one yeah it's the it's like the whole
squid is on top of it oh that's called a
fish squares it's a it's a small yeah
yeah it's like it's like a type of squid
yeah yeah that one even I think it's
called yeah even I'm not a big fan of
that one it's something just really
chewy yeah I just get through this one
yeah it tastes like nothing yeah
um I happily introduced them to fatty
tuna though
oh that's like like if if you want to
introduce your family or someone foreign
to something that you could it's really
hard to get outside of Japan unless you
pay up the ass and they're like that all
of them they [__] love that it's got
fats man of course man of course yeah
yeah
um because like tutor on Otoro it's kind
of like it's kind of like just normal
tuna but just like Ace life wagy yeah
it's like the A5 wagy of tune uh of tuna
yeah which is good
um but surprisingly they actually
enjoyed most most of it I think the
salmon row was the only thing that they
really were just like it was that they
would try uni
no okay and that's from that's the one
where I understand that it's love for a
lot of people but I don't like uni
that's yeah that's the Dark Souls boss
of sushi right it's like it's like it's
the mama yeah
I think there's just something in it
that just doesn't drop like what don't
you like about it it's like a gas in my
mouth it's like I have like it's like a
bomb is going off of it really it's so
intense and strong because it's like
salty no it's not even that it's like
this is this is weird taste to it that
just isn't I don't know it's not nice
I've heard from people I've heard people
who don't like uni say that they don't
like it because it's like they just took
a mouthful of seawater
maybe that it tastes like it tastes like
soapy to me when I eat it it's like very
chemically like I don't know how to
replace it I just I've I've because you
always get it in the set yeah and I
always eat it because I don't want to
disrespect the dude yeah and I just kind
of like it's more of a you just fight
through it
right right I do the Matt Stoney
technique I'm like
oh delicious great yeah yeah it's really
weird because I remember when I first
moved to Japan uh first time I tried uni
wasn't a fan either it was something was
off about the taste and then I just had
this one great experience in Hokkaido
and of course yeah yeah that's where the
third eye of food
and then I had this one uni in Hokkaido
and then like a like we just talked
about something something in my brain
just like clicks and switch and it just
unlocked this new skill like uni skill
tree in my brain and then after that one
experience I [__] love uni yeah I
don't know what it is it was just having
like that perfect balance between
something it was like a little bit sweet
but just like the right kind of sweet
but also it's like a creamy salty type
of thing creamy salty and sweet yeah
like one little package so did you did
you take them to like a sushi chain or
like some fancy place oh no honestly
because uh
yeah I'd say Sushi Rose solid bro yeah I
don't hate it yeah I mean we went to uh
so first place Sydney wanted to take
them was ask us sir you know kind of
like you know do the rounds of nasakusa
and we just went to uh it was
unsurprisingly very busy so we went to a
sushi restaurant that seemed to be a
local place there uh didn't have an
English menu so that's so that's that's
why I was less full than some of the
other sushi places
um so it was kind of like a lot it
wasn't a chain it was just like a local
locally run sushi place
um and yeah uh they very much enjoyed
the sushi experience which was good got
the good first pass uh took the round
ascusa uh which was
taking people around USA I didn't heard
anyone pronounce it that way yeah
that's my shitty pronounce here it's
confusing because there's asaksa and
then there's yeah as well yeah uh yeah
showed them showed them the temple and
everything like that and I think they
got a bit shocked where uh not not
shocked but it's uh they saw like the
trust system in full effect where you
know like when you get like the uh or
the omiguji yeah yeah uh and there's no
one there's no one looking but you have
to like pay 100 100 yen just to get your
fortunes done and stuff like that
there's no one looking at all you could
just you could just get yourself you
could just take one you could just take
one and uh you know no one's looking and
uh and that's when I had to explain to
them about Japan's trust system where
you are Americans just I still waiting
there are some places in Europe in
America that I I have it like in rural
areas oh yeah yeah for sure they have um
like Farms have you know you can just
but you pan is one of the few places I
feel when they also do it in urban areas
yeah yeah like more commonly than other
places I feel for sure for sure yeah